in order to be a great boring thrower
you have to be a scientist
you have to be an inventor you have to
be a craftsman and you get to wear all
these different hats in order to become
a great athlete in sport my name is
Logan Broadbent and I remember the World
Champion us boomerang T Broadbent is one
of the best boomerang throwers in the
world when I tell people I'm on the US
boomerang team the first thing that
comes to their mind is one we have a
u.s. boomerang team you've got to be
kidding right but it's true and we've
had the chance to travel all over the
world throwing catching boomerangs it
takes a lot to do well in the sport from
making custom gear to understanding the
science behind boomerang flight
mastering all this slop competitors
succeed in events design a test specific
skills like speed accuracy and distance
there's even one event that judges how
long the boomerang stays in the air and
another called trick catch and doubling
where you actually throw two boomerangs
at once and you have to catch them
behind the back under the legs with your
feet do all sorts of different catches
to earn points so I've actually been
throwing boomerangs since before I could
walk
and it's because my dad was involved in
the sport for years and years before me
he was one of the earliest competitors
in the sport of boomerangs even from a
young age I was going to different
tournaments with him you know learning
the different events becoming pretty
good pretty early at age 14 Robin was
the youngest person ever to join the
u.s. boomerang team since then they
picked up three World Championship
titles and frot been currently ranked
second in the world as an individual he
also holds the u.s. record for distance
177 yards all the way out with the full
return 177 yards back and he's one of
the few boomerang throws in the world
that can do this incredible
[Music]
so backflip catch we don't actually have
to do in competition I just think it's
fun to do especially in a crowd or for
my friends it's not just about fun
competitors need to understand how
boomerangs fly to do well in the sport
so there's actually a lot of physical
principles that are operating on a
boomerang in flight so what makes a
boomerang come back includes gyroscopic
precession differential lifts
centrifugal force momentum of inertia
angular momentum and torque okay so
basically the best way to think of it is
that each wing is an airplane wing and
this airfoil allows the boomerang to
generate lift but a boomerang is thrown
vertically so the direction of lift is
to the side unlike an airplane flying
horizontal where the direction of lift
is up in the air so you throw it nice
and vertical straight up and down it'll
curve around and come back and whether
it's a two wing boomerang like the
traditional ones that we think of or
three wing boomerang they're both
operating off the exact same principles
of flight getting as good as broadbent
takes time and practice but the first
step is mastering a basic throw all
boomerangs in the world are thrown
straight up and down nice and vertical
you always want the top side of the
boomerang facing you that's a side with
the airfoil it's also the side that's
painted and if you're a right-handed
thrower you want the wind hitting your
left cheek coming across from left to
right if you're a left-handed thrower
you'll actually be throwing with the
wind coming from right to left typically
I will pinch grip the boomerang so I'll
use my thumb and my index finger to hold
it this way sometimes you'll wrap the
front finger around the boomerang if you
need to get a little bit more power or a
little more grip but there's really no
wrong way to do it as long as you're
throwing it nice and vertical straight
out in front of you you don't have to
throw it high you don't throw it low
vertical is probably the most important
part competitive boomerang throwing may
not be a well known sport but there are
a few things most people do know about
boomerangs they come from Australia and
they were used as weapons except that's
not exactly true
so the returning boomerang was never
actually used as a weapon what was used
as a weapon by the Aborigines called a
Kylee was much larger and heavier than a
typical returning boomerang and it would
travel in a straight line so almost like
an aerodynamic baseball
that was used to bring down game there
were civilizations all over the world
that had throw sticks King Tut's tomb in
Egypt had had throw sticks the Hopi
Indians of the Southwest had throw
sticks so there's all these different
you know examples of throw sticks being
used before we invented bows and arrows
and other forms of weaponry but the
returning boomerang was never actually
used to hit anything so you may think
what's so difficult about boomerangs
right I mean you're throwing and
catching in the same place well it
actually involves a lot of athleticism
to be able to throw and catch a
boomerang consistently and in the
different ways that we have to do it in
competition especially considering how
fast the boomerangs fly they're moving
anywhere from 80 to 90 miles per hour
when they're leaving your hand and then
they're coming back a little bit slower
maybe slowing down to 60 miles per hour
by the time you're catching it and they
fly in all sorts of conditions even the
simplest catches require a surprising
amount of skill and physical stamina
oftentimes it's windy so it does require
a little bit of running around and being
able to react to changes in the flight
and you know boomerang throwers tend to
be very agile they tend to be very quick
they tend to be able to react quickly to
- to changes as boomerang competitors
were not able to practice every single
day it would just be way too much wear
and tear on our shoulders and on our
elbows so we have to do a lot of
different cross-training to stay fit
which gives Broadbent an advantage I'm
actually an endurance athlete by trade I
do marathons I do triathlons I also am
big in the obstacle course racing scene
which is another fast-growing sport but
all of those things help contribute to
making me a much better boomerang
competitor but athleticism isn't all it
takes to be a great boomerang thrower
the ability to adjust for different
conditions is important as well every
single event requires a different type
of boomerang but what's also important
to remember is that we're up against
mother nature a little wind let's wait
for that slow down for a sec so when the
winds are kicking up or if it's raining
or if you're at a higher altitude you
need to think about how that's going to
affect the flight of a boomerang which
means the right gear is critical so
critical in fact the competitive
boomerang throwers don't actually buy
their gear off
so what's unique about our sport is that
we actually make the equipment that we
use in competition so many of my
boomerangs were either made by me or
many were made by my teammates as well
if you're able to make good boomerangs
they work really well in different
conditions then that gives you a bit of
an edge so the one thing you'll notice
about all my boomerangs is that they're
super bright colors it's almost like
they're straight out of the 80s maybe
like those MC Hammer pants that that my
parents used to wear but what's
important about that is these need to be
visible in flight so I need to be able
to identify these quickly and easily
especially if they get caught in the Sun
and so so they're super bright super
bright colors some of them aren't that
pretty but sometimes the ugliest
boomerangs actually fly the best and
that's important to remember is
competitor getting a competitive edge in
the sport takes a lot of boomerangs
Bradburn carries almost a hundred
different kinds in this competition kit
all of these are made for different
events and they're made for different
weather conditions so I have three
bladed boomerangs two bladed boomerangs
even for winged boomerangs depending on
the event and they're all made out of
different types of materials so
boomerang technologies actually come a
really long way when most people think
of a boomerang they think of a two wing
two almost v-shaped type of boomerang
something a little bit more traditional
we can still throw these and they work
really really well but now we still make
boomerangs out of birch aircraft grade
plywood this actually has lead weights
embedded in the tips of each to get it
to go over 50 metres out we have a glass
infused nylons and different types of
plastic materials PE t polypropylene all
sorts different types of plastic we use
phenolic materials these are doublers
for trick catch we'll have sheet carbon
fiber which is a very rigid material but
still very lightweight so that makes for
a really nice boomerang and we even make
composite maximum time of loft
boomerangs so these are made out of
micro balloons and epoxy covered in
carbon and Kevlar fibers so they're
really ultralight but still very rigid
and they're made to stay in the air as
long as possible
some of the boomerangs that I throw make
a really cool sound when they leave my
hand and that's because a lot of them
actually have holes and different types
of slots built into the boomerangs to
create drag and then make some really
amazing sounds understanding the physics
behind boomerang flight is key in
competition as boomerang competitors the
more that we understand the physics and
the aerodynamics happening and how to
modify our boomerangs to get them to
operate the way we want them to operate
the bigger the advantage we have in
competition the rowers modify their gear
adding materials like tape rubber bands
and coins to get their boomerangs to
fight just right so if I want to add
drag it helps slow down the spin rate
and higher wind conditions I may add a
couple rubber bands on there if I want
to add a little more weight to get it to
go further to stay more vertical in
flight or even to lay out quicker
I have pennies on each one of these
wings not only does it depend what
you're putting on the boomerang but
where it's placed also plays an
important role in the boomerangs flight
and then oftentimes we'll even tune our
boomerangs so we may even twist a wing
giving it more angle of attack which is
going to shorten the range or we may
twist negative angle of attack getting
it to fly further if we Bend it up the
boomerang will fly higher if we bend a
wing down it'll fly lower in flight so
understanding all of those different
things you know obviously leads to being
a better competitor the one thing that I
love about boomerangs is they can be a
metaphor for life what goes around comes
around throw good out you'll get good
back if you're a good person good
citizen I think good things can happen
to you
[Music]
you